president Trump's former lawyer and
fixer says he is now willing to
cooperate with Special Counsel Robert
Muller Cohen alleges that then candidate
Donald Trump knew in advance about a
controversial June 2016
Trump Tower meaning where Russians were
expected to give damaging information on
Hillary Clinton now this claim would
contradict repeated denials by the
president and what the president's son
and son-in-law have said under oath
major Garrett is at the White House
major good morning good morning about
the story a couple of things worth
taking note of first Cohen says he has
no evidence to corroborate this charge
that then candidate Trump knew in
advance about this 2016 meeting to Cohen
has not been a particularly or his
special counsel investigators and matter
of fact they're not even handling the
investigation into Cohen's conduct
that's being dealt with by the US
Attorney's Office in the Southern
District of New York as for White House
reaction nothing from this building but
the Presidents attorney Rudy Giuliani
called Cohen a pathological liar there's
no way you're going to bring down the
president United States on the testimony
uncorroborated of a proven liar
president Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
slammed Michael Cohen saying he lacks
credibility he's got nothing to give
says it all of a sudden at the 11th hour
I don't think anybody believes that
Cohen is willing to testify before
Special Counsel Robert Muller that the
president knew about a 2016 Trump Tower
meeting involving the president's son
Donald Trump jr. son-in-law Jared
Kushner and then campaign Chairman Paul
Manafort along with the Russian lawyer
Cohen reportedly did not say that Trump
had advanced knowledge of that meeting
in private testimonies last year to two
congressional committees investigating
Russian interference in the 2016
election mr. Trump has previously denied
any knowledge of that Trump Tower
meeting when asked about the meeting
last July the president told reporters I
only heard about it two or three days
ago it was such a nothing there was
nothing to tell echoing Trump jr. who
told Senate investigators last September
that his father wasn't aware of it I
wouldn't have wanted to get him involved
in it because
had nothing to do with him on Thursday
the president ignored questions about
his former friend and fixer Cohen who is
currently under federal investigation
for possible campaign violations
Giuliani says until Cohen provides
evidence
it's just his word against the
president's can he corroborated write if
you can't corroborate it it's useless
Donald Trump's attorney said in a
statement his client quote has been
professional and responsible throughout
the Muller and congressional
investigation Gail the Office of Special
Counsel and Cohen's attorney had no
comment all right thank you very much
major